here are the nominees for achievement in
art direction Alice in Wonderland
production design by Robert Stromberg
and set decoration by Karin O'Hara Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 1
production design by Stuart Craig and
set decoration by Stephanie McMillan
inception production design by guy
Hendrix diets and set decoration by
Larry Dias and Doug Mullen The King's
Speech production design by Eve Stewart
and set decoration by Judy for True Grit
production design by Jess Gahan Shore
and set decoration by Nancy hey and the
Oscar goes to Alice in Wonderland robert
stromberg about to design karen O'Hara
set deck
[Applause]
this is the second Academy Award and
nomination for robert stromberg this is
the first Oscar and second nomination
for Karen O'Hara
oh why didn't I lose that twenty pounds
uh so every what well first of all the
other nominees guy all you guys deserve
to be up here
everyone at Disney from Eiger and Ross
and Bailey Bruce Hendrix our Tripoli the
great Joe Roth art department led by
Stefan deccan Christie Wilson and tot
renowned ski this great set set
decorator I'm standing here for because
of three people Ken Ralston the great
Richard zanuck and the wacky world of
Tim Burton there he is
meet me with a saw because half of this
is yours
it's just one last bit of art direction
for a Tim Burton film there it is thank
you Academy and to my wife my kids I
dedicate this to my dad thank you
[Applause]